welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker and I'm
here with Darren mcke Darren is the
author of the upcoming book
uncontrollable and he's the he's the
host of the reality check podcast he's
also been a senior policy advisor for 15
years Darren welcome to the podcast Hi
Gus pleasure to be here fan of the show
I had a great time reading your book and
one of your goals with the book is to
take a a complex topic like machine
learning AI research and in particular
alignment research and then present it
in an accessible way how do you go about
a task like that well it was a bit
difficult and I think Clarity above all
else I've been following the AI
developments for we'll say a decade or
two uh sometimes deeply sometimes
Loosely and I would read know the
popular books and some of the Articles
and have discussions about all these
things but it was really around April
May 2022 when I thought oh wow things
are are really picking up and I think a
lot of people felt that when the
spaculus projection for AGI dropped
about 10 years everyone's like oh oh
things are things are happening right
and at that point I thought okay I think
there's a gap between readily available
materials that reach a wider audience
and the speed at which AI is progressing
and so I thought there's an opportunity
here to write a book it's not that uh
materials didn't exist at all there's
Forum posts there's blogs there's lots
of podcasts there's videos and so on but
I thought it'd be nice it would be
pulled together in uh a book we'll say
for people with no technical background
even no science background and so that's
where some of my experience with the
podcast or policy where you're trying to
kind of do knowledge translation take a
complicated idea try to rephrase it
simply accessibly and relate to an
audience and with that as a context uh
the the the journey began so to speak so
since last June 2022 I've been trying to
work on this book and I'm happy that
it's done and I've tried to make a
really concerted effort from the design
of the cover to the table of contents to
the chapters to how they flow it really
is trying to put yourself in the mind of
someone who is curious about AI they've
seen these news headlines they're
interested maybe concerned confused what
the heck is going on with AI and that's
who this book is for so it's not so much
for the technical people it's not for
the people who've been in this AI safety
debate for many years although hopefully
they'll get some value it's more in a
way for the people they know that that
can help perhaps explain some of the
issues to them yeah and I'll just say
this I I've been reading about AI I've
been interested in in AI for for a long
time and this book still provided the
value to me so as there's there's value
in going over the basics again I would
say we're also in this um conversation
going to go over some of the basics
again and there are interesting choices
about how how you frame different issues
uh which analogies you use and so on I'm
interested in how do you balance acccess
ability with accuracy so I imagine that
you know an expert is going to read this
book How do you how do you deal with
that fact when you're when you're
writing for a a a broader audience but
you might get a nitpicky expert uh
critiquing your book I think there's
just going to be some inherent
trade-offs uh the goal is to reach as I
said as many people as possible because
the experts they already know these
things they already have materials that
are available more readily to them but
for the average person to have something
really explained in a book form I think
this is kind of the first of its kind it
is entirely dedicated to the AI safety
argument and tries to reach people as
accessibly as possible my own background
science and Academia I am also inclined
towards accuracy and even precision and
trying to understand the difference
between accuracy and precision but also
understanding that for the audience I'm
trying to reach the difference between
accurate and precision isn't what
matters it what is the main idea uh is
there rigor like is what I'm saying
generally true or understood to be true
is there evidence to support it does it
make sense but I did try to be we'll say
a bit more flexible by how I might
phrase certain things and how I might
use certain analogies to try to meet the
audience where they are as you said this
field is very very complicated and you
have to make concessions somewhere when
you're explaining things to people what
did you do when in your research You
Came Upon a topic on which the experts
disagreed so this is this is often the
case in alignment research for example
the experts disagree about the basics
what do you do then when you're trying
to explain the basics so I think it's
there's a couple options there it was my
Approach was generally to try to give I
won't say the generally accepted uh
consensus because there well there is a
consensus of sorts but not unanimity
everyone doesn't fully agree and no one
ever does and that's true let's be
honest for everything when you look at
the surveys um of you know what the
philosophers believe there's fundamental
differences same thing with economists
same thing with physicists same thing
with pretty much every discipline so
understanding that the book is trying to
be a bit of a neutral Observer but at
the same time I have a perspective I've
looked at these issues I am concerned
we're trying to figure it out together
but I'm giving reasons why I think AI
safety is a concern to be more specific
I kind of tried to be sympathetic to all
sides but at the same time I probably
didn't get too much into the weeds if
people thought there's no concern at all
I might mention the uncertainty around
everything but not so much giving that a
lot of weight because I think there are
reasons to to be concerned to take a
step back the book the structure to try
to give people a sense of how I did it
is you look at the debates or
discussions that are occurring in the AI
risk AI safety space and what do people
seem to get stuck on what are their
disagreements what are their cruxes what
might be the underlying we'll say uh
intellectual or even emotional
dispositions that are leading people to
have certain beliefs and then
identifying that thinking about which
part of the AI issue relates to it and
then trying to think about an analogy or
a simple way to explain the thing
related to AI so IT addresses the
underlying issue in the future debate
it's a bit complicated but it's kind of
like working backwards and then forwards
so if I think one of the issues is it's
really hard to imagine how powerful
something like an advanced AI or super
intelligence could be the first chapter
of the book uh is a lot about how a
powerful intelligence is or the
importance of imagination like is it
really that it's a failure of
imagination that's driving a lot of this
well not everything of course but I
think it's a factor so then I'm trying
to address aspects of how imagination
might work or just open up people's
minds why don't we put it that way about
what's possible before I even talk about
AI because it's a general issue about
trying to be open-minded about what
could happen and with that in place
hopefully later when there's more AI
stuff it's just less likely to be a
problem it is still hard to imagine
something as smart as an a ASI or
artificial super intelligence but we can
try to at least acknowledge that there's
something there there's something to be
understood or even that we don't know
exactly what it could be and that's its
own value So you you're right about how
the range of intelligence extends much
further than than we might normally
imagine what what intuitions do you rely
on here how do you explain why is that
why is that the case sure I think
there's um you know the human brain is
great right I like mine even though it's
flawed I don't know what I'd do without
it but when we interact in the world we
have our kind of default settings we
know there's various biases and the
availability bias and other things that
when you're asked a question or you're
quickly reading something whatever pops
in seems to be how you might think or
feel about a subject if given a direct
question by someone you might reflect a
bit more and think a bit differently but
I'm trying to shift a bit out of that
default so when we navigate the world we
kind of think of the intelligence mostly
of our friends or I ask people to
imagine like the smartest person they
know and they have that person in mind
I'm like okay now imagine the smartest
person you think ever existed maybe it's
uh Einstein or Mary cury or Von neyman
or whoever it is and so right away
you're like okay well I had the smartest
person that I know personally and the
smartest person ever like well could
there be even people who are smarter and
I give some examples of savants who have
incredible abilities whether it's
memorization or processing information
visually or auditorially whatever it is
and like well look humans already can do
some amazing things which that smartest
person you know Von neyman may be an
exception can't really do so it's kind
of trying to show let's think about what
might be possible and then giving
examples of what already is possible to
help people understand okay if this is
possible and it's already happened could
we imagine a little bit more right a
little bit higher I also go the other
way looking at uh capacities of animals
and we look at you know briefly you like
in a page it's it's you know birds and
you have fish and you have dolphins and
so on and we know broadly humans are
more intelligent than these other
creatures um not to say all humans right
at all times of their lives than all the
other creatures of course but broadly as
a general truth that's the case and when
we think about say why gorillas are in
our zoos and we're not in theirs it's
not strength right it's not our good
looks it's not our charm it's because
again collectively we have an
intelligence capability that is beyond
theirs and that's another Nuance that
when I use intelligence it's a bit more
like Anthropologist Joseph henrik's sort
of cumulative cultural Collective
capital in terms of intelligence it's
very Broad and encumbers because I
thought that was probably the best way
to try to communicate how important it
is yeah why do you think we forget or at
least this is my experience I'm
intellectually aware of all of these
examples you just gave I know there are
people that are much smarter than me and
I know there are Savant and so on but it
seems to me that when I when I think in
in normal life I deceive myself into
thinking that the range of of
intelligence is ends at at at at at my
height basically that that that this is
that I represent the the the basic range
of intelligence is there do you think
this is common why is it hard to imagine
abilities that are Beyond us that's a
great question I'm not sure of detailed
research but I do think it is somewhat
common we kind of think we're the
example right this sort of Mind
projection fallacy or typical mind
fallacy as it's thought I'm sort of the
Baseline if things are different than me
then that's how I calibrate them right
if we say someone is taller or short
sometimes that's in reference to
ourselves but often it's sort of some
general vague notion of the population
uh of course if you're 65 6'5 inches uh
that makes you very tall unless you're
in the NBA then it's average and so we
do understand there is a frame of
reference but again the default setting
of human brains again they're great but
we can't be thinking in complexity that
much complexity all the time working
space memory is tapped so if you're just
you know trying to I don't know make
dinner or you want to read an article H
to then think of like oh there's a 15 to
30 things I should always have in mind
while I'm doing this that's great I
applaud the effort and I try to have a
couple in mind but it's almost
impossible to do so in that sense uh the
book can also serve to just remind
people of things that they already know
it's very hard to even for me to talk
about like well do I have a three 350
page book memorized yet not entirely but
the ideas are more frequently in there
and they're more likely to come to mind
so with intelligence I think it really
is just almost asking yourself more
often am I making the right projection
is this a fair generalization am I
inadvertently benchmarking to the wrong
set or the wrong base line and in time
through human history is what I mean to
say humans now in various places are on
average much more intelligent than they
were in the past and that's mainly due
to education and socialization nutrition
diet these sorts of things I think if
you look approximately 100,000 200,000
years ago genetically humans are very
similar of course if you go you know a
million years ago then it's quite
different uh but it's not staggeringly
different compared to the other species
entirely all I have to say is that why
humans are so capable now is because of
our nutrition our socialization and the
fact we live in a world that does a lot
of the work for us uh as I say like you
know can you build a fire well many
people can and many people can't and
what's worse is some of us can't build a
fire even with matches we know what
we're supposed to do right you get some
kindling you get some paper you get some
lighter you get some thicker wood and
you have the matches and you you do a
decent job it starts and then it Fizzles
out and it's like oh I can't even build
fire despite knowing how to do it and
starting with matches well that's
embarrassing again this is easily
rectified if you practiced but I don't
necess have to know this because there
are matches and there are lighters and
other people have figured this out for
me so I can leverage the intelligence
and the efforts of other people so I
don't have to worry as much and perhaps
similarly it feels like you're one is an
individual super smart navigating
through the world you're like well
that's because everything else has been
done for you right now with computers
and phones most of the complexity is
behind the scenes and that's great for
us you press a button something works
what actually happens the Staggering
mindboggling complexity of information
in ones and zeros going across space and
time it's easy just not think about it
and in a way why would you if you're
trying to watch a movie you're not going
to think of the Matrix decoded you could
but then you're going to ruin the
experience for yourself do you think we
are giving our Collective knowledge to
AIS by training them on all available
data online for example are we thereby
transferring the the collective
knowledge that we've built up that
allows us to succeed in daily life I
think we are it's almost like having a a
new child of sorts and you're
socializing it the way you might a
person so let's look at all what
Humanity has learned and we try to pass
that on to a new generation and we're
doing the same thing with AI just in a
much more dramatic complicated and U
again staggeringly vast way where
there's as you
know the amounts of data that adab byes
zettabytes I can't remember exactly what
the the number is that's going into
these systems or would or could go into
these systems I should say it's not
quite that high yet but uh why not have
all the world some knowledge uh
available and it's only going to get
better and better I think there's vast
data sources that haven't been fully
tapped right so you think of all the
video which programs are now starting to
mine both you can just take the audio
from it which has its own value but even
the movements how people move what they
show and how that sort of thing happens
that could be you know whether it's you
know fixing a a chair or the sink but
it's also how people navigate what they
pck attention to and what they don't and
so once all the video gets recorded and
all the radio and there's all these
different data sources that I think
it'll be even more staggering uh so yes
we're we're kind of giving Humanity
everything that we've ever done that's
in record over to AIS and that will have
of course a very fantastic wonderful
things one hopes but also a lot of risks
and concerns given our troubles with
understanding other people's minds how
can we hope to understand AI systems yes
I think that's a great question I am
optimistic but I think it's going to be
definitely a challenge I mean there's a
there's a broader idea here is that this
is what we need to work on there are
many things related to AI that are going
to be very difficult and whether we're
hopeful or not we have to realize that
we have to try we have to try to figure
it out how they work why they're doing
what they're doing and yeah it might be
complicated but Humanity has figured out
the impossible before that goes back to
the imagination issue if you look at
what we kind of take for granted now
that humans have gone to the Moon that
we're having this conversation again
across space and time relatively easily
this is not only uh odd or unlikely or
improbable this is impossible to people
from the past and beyond that I actually
want to argue that it's Unthinkable they
if you go far enough back they didn't
have the conceptual apparatus to even
consider how difficult this could be and
that's also a shift where you're
thinking okay imagine gazing up at the
Moon as a lot of humanity has done
throughout our history well how do you
get there you can't just like climb a
tree you can't you know you build you
can build a tall structure as many did
and you a mountain a temple these sorts
of that tall ladder but the idea that
you could build a ship or a rocket and
actually fly there that would have
seemed it wouldn't even occurred to
people it just would have been out of
their reach at the time and it's within
our reach again just because we happen
to be born at this time so uh it allows
for what's possible well with the AI at
the moment it seems very very difficult
given how these systems are as people
say almost grown rather than built to
know exactly what's going on given the
complexity of our artificial neural
networks and the size of the parameters
and all these models that said I think
uh there's a lot of good efforts to try
to figure things these things out and
that's exactly why we need like more
investment in AI safety and more people
to try to help us one hangup people have
about AI safety is thinking about the
goals of AI systems so why is it that AI
systems might develop goals that are
contrary to ours why would they suddenly
turn evil uh is a question you could ask
there you you talk about you use the
virus analogy so maybe you could you
could explain how you use that so I
think there's kind of a two-step process
here whether AI systems have goals or
not and I'll take each in turn with the
virus why don't we do just do that first
a virus doesn't have goals but it can
still harm you and I think that's just a
great analogy and you can think of the
you know sort of biological virus but
there's also computer viruses uh
biological viruses depending on what
they are we know they're very hard to
contain they can cause pandemics they
can cause illness they Comm when flu
these sorts of things computer viruses
uh people not in Tech aren't aware that
there's some still crawling the internet
that were developed years and years ago
that we can't really stop but that's the
default World we're in so these things
are created and they get out of control
these things computer and biological
virus it doesn't need a goal to harm you
it doesn't need an intention it's kind
of just following a process in the
biological sense an evolved mechanism
whether viruses are alive is a debate we
don't need to get into but it's trying
to achieve certain objectives and you
can describe it as if it has a goal
because it's easier to kind of navigate
the world it reduces complexity but you
could also argue of course it doesn't
have goals it's a virus it's a little
thing why would a computer virus have a
goal it doesn't and in the book I
acknowledge this but I kind of just go
with the as if goals let's not get into
a protracted philosophical debate about
whether something has goals or not if it
acts as if it has goals and it's useful
to treat it that way then let's just do
that it's much easier and this is and
for anyone curious this is totally
dennett's int stance type stuff coming
in here because I'm a huge fan of
philosopher Daniel dennet and like what
are we trying to do here what we're
trying to protect ourselves from
computer viruses or biological viruses
and you can think oh the virus is trying
to get you the flu is trying to infect
you when someone coughs or sneezes it's
trying to spread well of course it's not
trying to spread organism has engaged an
activity which makes it more likely to
replicate but to say that every time you
know it just becomes very uh burdensome
so sentences become paragraphs
paragraphs becomes many paragraphs and
that's why we sort of circumvented so
that's the first bit about why it might
have goals in an as if sense and then
there's the other part where okay so if
something becomes a bit more autonomous
uh does it come to have goals and I
think you know we can look at different
organisms again as an understanding that
autonomy falls on a Continuum does
something have a goal or not well in
some ways yes in some ways no the chess
playing program does it want to win well
it sure acts like it wants to win and
when I lose I feel like it beat me
versus like some computer code and some
people designed it the designers
definitely designed it to have a range
of skills so it could be me does do
worms have goals do cats have goals do
dogs have goals to orangutans have goals
well of course in some ways they
definitely engage in goal directed
Behavior because they're trying to
achieve a certain objective and
similarly with AI systems we already
have various we'll say automated
programs that have autonomy and they
need to have autonomy in some way to act
in the world this would be the stock
trading platforms that already function
uh all the time uh credit card bank
fraud detection numerous other sort of
monitoring of systems type uh algorithms
and whatnot function in an automatic
process because they couldn't keep
checking with a human and even in the
military typically there is a human in
the loop but we know for say missile
defense uh these things are automated
often because there's no way a human
could react quickly enough to stop
incoming missiles so it's not that
whether computers become more a sorry
autonomous at all it's that to what
degree are they going to become more
autonomous and I think that is a much
larger conversation but at the same time
you could see while would be incentives
to have things become more automatic
which means a bit more empowered which
will then translate to seeming like they
have goals and at one point the seeming
goals Blends enough into the well that
looks like it has goals that I'm just
going to say it has goals if we return
to the virus analogy one thought I have
there is whether the existence of the
common cold for example the common cold
is not very smart it's pretty dumb I I
imagine
and it's also very harmful and and
costly to society does this mean that
intelligence is
not necessary to cause harm is this a
decoupling of intelligence and Power in
the world a great point so I think as
you just said it's not a necessary
condition in that case but that's
different from whether intelligence is a
factor that becomes correlated with the
ability to cause more harm so you're
right that a virus will say it's pretty
simple uh pretty straightforward
not that many moving pieces compared to
other organisms and it can cause drastic
amounts of harm but you know you're not
going to you know go watch a movie with
a virus and then talk about its thoughts
after is just not that type of thing but
as you scale up the uh abilities or the
intelligence capabilities of different
entities they do have a different
capability for harm so viruses can just
infect you but something with more
intelligence could design viruses to
infect you design even worse viruses and
even more dramatically you know well if
something's smart enough it might be
able to deflect an incoming asteroid and
save us in a way so it's not just
harmful but it's the other side too the
benefits so I think intelligence is a
factor and in some cases it becomes a
very significant factor in the ability
to cause harm versus not as anyone who's
like taking care of a child a very young
child can cause a lot of harm but
they're relatively relatively
containable if you have the right crib
if you have the right Gates uh they can
usually be at least put in a certain
place that's partly due to mobility and
partly due to intelligence same thing
with various other animals but as you
Ranch it up the intelligence to sort of
contain something or control it it
becomes increasingly difficult to the
point where it's uh very very difficult
to contain some very intelligent
entities now there are lots of
definitions of artificial general
intelligence out there and and you use
one in the book that I that I quite like
maybe you could talk about the average
office worker or the average remote
worker so uh artificial general
intelligence or AGI as people say it's
it's very much in the news right how
long till AGI what is Agi and so on and
the approach I took in the book again
for access accessibility I'm not trying
to make the definitive definition I just
want a good enough definition so people
could understand what we're talking
about and I thought in the most
accessible way and with those uh factors
in mind okay what are we talking about
here it's usually someone's concerned
about employment primarily and so I was
thinking could someone replace me at
work and so if you T kind of take the
average coworker idea that's the
foundation if you're interacting with a
co-worker say it's a remote remote
coworker right it's still focused on the
way on intellectual tasks so it's a
computer system that you know does
intellectual tasks as good as an average
person and that's really the foundation
where you could imagine if someone's
performing as an average cooworker level
they're doing General tasks to a certain
capability and therefore you could see
why that person may be sorry that entity
may be employable or why it might affect
employment and it seemed to I guess as I
said hit home in the best way as a as a
Nuance here why use that terminology at
all is a question I asked myself because
like well do I need to introduce these
terms to the average person why why not
well they seem pretty popular right
that's one thing so you meet people
where they are and I knew the world was
going to talk about AGI in one way or
another now is it better to say human
level because it's almost the same in
some ways but at the same time we use
the term AI a lot right and that's you
sort of like why did I use intelligence
artificial intelligence artificial
general intelligence and artificial
super intelligence is because I thought
you know what most people are going to
talk about Ai and people kind of know
what AI is so once you accept artificial
intelligence as a foundation to make
things as easy as possible schol going
down one in a way is intelligence
broadly and then going another level is
artificial general intelligence and then
Super intelligence and I thought that
four-part kind of structure was the best
way to frame things I imagine that you
decided to to write the book out of some
sense of urgency now you you give a lot
of Uncertain you you present the
uncertainty around uh what is called AI
timelines in the book you must be
motivated in some sense by by urgency
about uh the the speed at which AI is
developing do you want to give us your
AI timelines do you want to tell us uh
how how long it is until we have AGI how
long do we have left um I don't
necessarily think that I don't want to
be dramatic but so I think it's a great
point and I'll I'll elaborate a bit that
I don't want to HED so I think something
like the average cooworker sure it could
be plausible within three years two to
three four years I'm being a bit vague
because I almost feel like that's not
what's as important as the fact that
there's a lot of good data that shows
capabilities are dramatically increasing
this is the basics of more investment
and computational power better design of
chips new Chips coming online to the
extent that nvidia's h100s are being
shipped so the big players open Ai and
deep mind will probably start training
their next gen models and all these
things and then of course a couple years
after that there's even more powerful
chips that are planned by Nvidia and all
these designers so the the the path the
most likely outcome seems to be
increasing computational power which
then has some relationship to increased
AI capabilities and we don't quite know
how the input matches the output which
is itself a concern there's that
uncertainty there but the the trend
lines are things are going to get more
powerful and things are going to get
more capable and because of that it does
seem like AGI or even a artificial super
intelligence I think that's within 10
years I think that is entirely plausible
again this is not 100% estimate but I
think it's plausible enough now in the
in the the regular listeners of the show
might be like well did he mean 30% 60%
or 85% I understand the T tendency for
that I think it's the average person is
like well is it going to happen or is it
not like 10% 50% 100% so it's definitely
never 100 because all knowledge is
probabilistic and there's uncertainty
everywhere but why I spent some time on
the book with the uncertainty is the
uncertainty is concerning it's not that
things get better when we say we don't
know I think sometimes people hear like
well it could be two years away it could
be 10 years away 10 20 years away and
they kind of just leave it at that like
wait a minute if you don't know it could
be two years away so how do we make
decisions faced with uncertainty we
always have to right the world is full
of complexity and uncertainty and
decisions have to be made and it's
tempting to think decisions don't have
to be made that you can just be agnostic
it doesn't quite work that way now you
know this is more just me highlighting a
complexity of the world everyone can't
care about every issue everyone can't
read up and be knowledgeable about every
issue but I do want to highlight that if
you're happen to be in the AI space and
you say we don't know that's almost more
concerning than someone that says it's 5
years away because if you actually mean
we don't know tomorrow a month from now
and like oh no no I don't mean that I
mean you know there's a 1% chance in the
next 15 years like oh okay so you do
have something right I guess I'm trying
to highlight that again the human brain
we go through life and we're making
probability based decisions in a very
loose sense whether you get a mortgage
whether you might have kids whether you
get a certain insurance and for how long
these are often based on some sense of
what the future is going to be like
similarly when we're engaging with AI
stuff we are making decisions or not
based on what the future is like now you
could say there's a disconnect between
what someone says and what they do and
behavior and that's that's true but
sometimes we're dramatically
inconsistent and no human is immune from
this right I won't eat junk food and
then I'm eating junk food what happened
well clearly there's conflicting
impulses within the human organism okay
but I really just want to sort of
highlight the complexity there and have
people reflect on okay I've said
something does my behavior match it in
any way and if things are that uncertain
isn't it better to be prepared than to
be caught off guard uncertainty isn't a
justification for complacency is another
way to put it we can do something we can
make plans and we should probably make
plans for each timelines you mentioned
in the book you discuss some cognitive
traits that AI might have and I think
this this was this was quite interesting
and starting with with speed so AIS will
think much faster than we do this is
something that's often overlooked I I
find in debates what does it mean if you
have human level AI but it thinks a 100
or thousand times faster than you is it
it's it is it still reasonable to call
it human level I'm happy you picked up
on that yeah so this goes to the what is
an ASI what kind of thing is it to try
to help people along we don't quite know
what an ASI might be or exactly how it
will be but I was trying to have people
understand what it might likely be and
so there's a couple key traits and then
a couple other possible ones uh so you
have speed in there we'll talk about
that first and there's capability
reliability and insight in these sorts
of things but as again just someone's
never talked about AGI or they've never
thought about super intelligence like
what the heck are these guys talking
about it's a computer system what what's
it going to look like and yes they'll
probably draw on science fiction or
popular movies and some of those are
misleading and some of those are useful
but it's like what are we talking about
so I thought very likely AI systems ASI
systems AGI systems will function very
quickly and this is because computers
generally work very quickly that's why
they're so amazing again people
listening to this are are ability to
record this meeting and discussion it's
because so many things are happening so
fast in a way that our brains can't
comprehend that it just seems smooth
seamless and easy so with an AI system
as you've seen it if you've ever used
you know any of the chat Bots the recent
models or even the image generators oh
let me think for a second and then out
out comes the output and it's usually
remarkable right it happens at a speed
that no human could possibly generate in
that amount of time and so I think there
it's it's the the the flaw or the I
would say the limitation of any
definition there's always going to be an
AS tricks where like well in other
context it's not quite like this that
famous berand Russell quote any
everything is vague to a degree you do
not realize until you've tried to make
it precise it really is the case because
any word you can find like well what
does this word mean and you know
sometimes people spend an entire thesis
or a book defining a word and then
someone argues it's not that word and
that sort of thing but anyway so with
AGI I think if we think about a general
ability we have to understand again the
coworker thing is useful as a sort of a
test it's sort of a clear bar now you
could say well aren't are different
types of co-workers in different types
of environments and some co-workers and
entire even Industries or companies in
different countries will be smarter or
more capable than other ones sure but we
have to have some way of talking about
this otherwise we kind of get lost and
at least I'm trying to be consistent uh
in that way so if it was the case that
your average coworker could do something
a thousand times faster than you it
doesn't quite seem like your average
cooworker anymore right and then it's
like well how do we deal with this then
like well when we examine people or give
them evaluations in their work Place
some people have strengths that other
people don't and there is some sort of
mishmash of like well are they
insightful are they analytical are they
on time are they you know friendly are
they good to work with all these
different things and it becomes an
amalgam of an evaluation and similar
with AI or AGI will sort of do something
similar I think in the practical sense
that if there's a task and it comes back
one second later and your colleague
would have taken three days well that's
not quite human level right that's above
human level now if it has errors that
the human never would have made like
well okay um that makes you maybe a bit
less in human level the AI gives you
something it takes you two days to fix
it and another process would have taken
three days well now it's above human
level but not as much as it seemed
originally it seems to me that we are in
front on the speed aspect with AI right
now so so AI will often if if we talk to
gbt 4 you get an answer almost instantly
uh the answer won't be as well done as a
human expert could so it seems to me
that we are in front on the speed uh
aspect but we are behind on the kind of
depth uh aspect as as things stand right
now who knows with the with the upcoming
models that might lead lead us into
talking about AI Insight which is kind
of you could think about it as the ai's
understanding of its context and the
relationships it's it's engaging in and
you expect AIS to to to have greater
insight and to understand their context
and understand their relationships
perhaps even even better than humans at
some point
why is that yes that's a great point
it's also something that gives me the
not the most concern but it is a concern
so we'll do like the first part first um
as you said before if if someone is
super fast but they're not necessarily
good at pattern detection or Insight
they're kind of missing a lot of what
makes um useful products services or
work in the broad sense and right now we
already have Al algorithms and whatnot
that can do sort of pattern detection in
a way that a human just can't right any
a way this is how most of the recommend
algorithms whether it's your Netflix or
online social media it's processing vast
amounts of data based on what you've
given it in terms of clicks likes even
just moments spent looking at something
and then spitting out something you
probably like to some extent or another
if a human was doing this I yeah give me
three months to analyze you know reams
of data and then I think this guy might
you know has a 70% chance of liking this
one YouTube video that's you know
actually impressive for the human but
not at all useful in the real world and
so as as they're designed right now now
the systems are already we'll say super
good at pattern detection and there's
even a story where some researchers were
doing different analyses and an AI was
able to detect a patient's race from
scans like X-rays of a person's body but
the researchers couldn't figure it out
they tried to realize or understand what
the AI system was doing because they
would block certain parts of the anatomy
like maybe it's the looking at the heart
or something at the lungs and they
couldn't figure it out now maybe there
is an answer because there has to be
some sort of thing the AI was doing but
it's already the casee where AI systems
can figure something out that humans
cannot and even after it's done humans
still can't and I think as you said
before the lag right now is not quite
the speed or even the inside it's almost
the integration the the flexibility in a
way the generality that right now humans
are very sophisticated General creatures
so if you give them an intellectual task
they can do a wide range of things but
also they do it in a certain way and the
world isn't yet restructured even how
you know people talk to these machines
that has a certain nuance and a
sophistication sort of like um well the
book purposely does not deal with
robotics because I think that's a
separate thing it's an interesting and
amazing thing but an Amazon warehouse
you can't just stick a robot in there or
automatic machines it has to be designed
in a certain way to have a true
efficiency and Effectiveness similarly I
think the chat Bots large language
models other AI systems in the future
will also provide Great Value but
they're not quite integrated in a way
that works the second thing when I said
the the Insight concerns me a bit is
again if you take a big step back um how
did humans manage to do what they do
right they managed to figure out how
things work like the laws of physics how
things fit together putting you know
different objects and different pieces
together we can sort of rearrange matter
to create things like cars like houses
like computers and this is also inspired
by David Deutsch beginnings of infinity
it's like well our brains just managed
to figure it out there's all this raw
material that was inside the earth and
we were able to take it out and refine
it and put it together and now we have
wonderful devices and that was hard and
difficult and I couldn't do it but
someone figured it out groups of people
teams of people generations of people
and that's amazing and the concern for
me sometimes is what if an AI That's
super insightful can sort of see the
universe in a way that we can't I'm not
saying it might unlock a truly new
fundamental law of physics that's a
possibility though but it is the case
like well what if you just sort of tilt
the world like this and like oh of
course of course Wi-Fi as a technology
it was always possible we just didn't
know how to do it and of course recently
people have shown you you can use Wi-Fi
as a way to sort of scan a room and
create models of where people are and
how they move and that of course was
also always possible the laws of physics
haven't changed in our lifetime and they
haven't changed as far as We Know Much
in 13.8 billion years since the birth of
the universe so it's really this Insight
that allows you to figure things out
which if you understand the world and
the universe more than other people you
can do dramatic things you can create a
wonderful inventions you also have a
huge advantage in terms of how to
manipulate systems or perhaps how to
escape from system systems where someone
else just didn't realize oh if you
manipulate the cooling fan in a computer
you might be able to gain access to
different things again that's pretty
remarkable it was always possible until
someone figured it out though we didn't
know yeah I do wonder whether AIS
Advanced AI will be able to solve some
of the science problems where humans
have been less successful so I think
we've been successful in domains that
are in some sense simple not simple to
understand but can re be reduced to
something simple like like physics as
soon as we get into something very
complex like biology or psychology we
haven't had had the same level of
success but I I I wonder whether AIS are
well suited to tasks where there's a lot
of data and it's complex data and
whether they might be able to make
progress such that they have superum
insight about our own minds that and you
could see how that would be dangerous uh
to be exposed to manipulation or
otherwise
being interacting with a system like
that I think it could also be amazing
right that's how most of this stuff goes
it cuts both ways the uncertainty Cuts
both ways I am uh just for listeners I
am a huge fan of science I have a Mas in
science I've always been a big fan of
science but it is also limited right we
know there are humans in a way we're a
bunch of Apes trying to figure things
out right and I think we've done pretty
well but we know there's limitations
there's replication crisis there's even
just the reality of millions of
scientific Publications each year who
can read all these and so I years ago
thought you know what humans should make
a good strong effort but won't it be
nice if some AI system picked your field
economics psychology biology chemistry
whatever it is and they could read a
thousand papers and like you know what
we need we need this particular type of
experiment that addresses these four
things that these thousand didn't in the
right way so that H you know at the
moment it actually feels me fills me
with like more happiness like oh we
might actually really figure things out
even though of course depending on
what's figured out it could be bad but
there's so many complexities here that
humans just can't easily disentangle
this is the pattern recognition this is
the Insight that I really hope uh with
AI systems we can make some dramatic
progress like okay you know that thing
we thought might have had an effect size
of you know a certain size or or not it
just isn't the case or it kind of is or
it's a 1% thing that people just
shouldn't pay much attention to given
this other thing which is much more
important so I'm I'm pretty um happy at
the moment of the idea of AI really
improving science while acknowledging
that depending on the field that could
also be a problem yeah I'm also pretty
excited for for seeing what AI can do in
the science realm I wonder if we can
create more systems like Alpha fold uh
deep Minds Alpha fold that that was able
to figure out how um yeah how proteins
fold where it's a system that's narrow
but highly capable in a specific domain
and helps us solve a long-standing
science problem I I I do I do think the
tradeoff between risk and reward is
pretty great for such systems do do you
think that's that's a potentially
responsible way forward to push hard on
narrow systems that help us with the
scientific problems I definitely do and
as you pointed out alphafold and other
highly capable narrow systems it's
amazing it's amazing what they've done
right and you know we're just getting
started type thing that said we know the
incentives for generality general
purpose systems is very high whether we
can kind of tweak people towards having
like look you want a certain capability
this is a particular problem it's in a
way easier to solve if you just focus on
it then why don't we focus on that that
said there's other problems where it
turns out being General is better right
and I think there's a there's a nuance
and a delicacy here or a complexity that
we're just going to kind of see how
things pan out I'm aware of Mustafa suan
he has a sort of personal assistant Ai
and their plan is not to make AGI but a
good personal assistant and I guess the
question is well are you gonna have to
end up making something like an AGI to
have a personal assistant that is as
good as the other personal assistants
that are more AGI like from other
companies and it seems like that's
probably the case it's kind of hard to
think why wouldn't it Go in this
direction um in terms of developing
systems as things get more capable again
the computational power that's coming on
board is staggering it's not clear if
it's even much work to kind of stick
something in on the side so to speak um
do we need like a single purpose machine
so to speak or can it be multiple things
in com combination and I know some of
the other AI labs are experimenting with
these types of things and even if the
machine or the AI is kind of isolated on
its own and has certain capabilities we
know once you connect it to numerous
other applications through through apis
or whatnot it becomes far far more
capable so I think it'd be nice if we
can focus on narrow things and I think
that's a good path forward and maybe
even like the most reasonable one if in
a risk averse cautious sense I'm I'm
wared about the viability of it that
said we should still try um and we're
kind of just kind of see how it plays
out but I think even if you make
something highly capable uh like Google
did with alphafold we're going to see
how it goes I mean Gemini their product
is supposed to come out I think within a
month or two and that's supposed to be
very identic and it's kind of like Alpha
fold plus the other one if you hear the
rumors and yeah can you get some sort of
I don't know amalgam Voltron thing we're
like well it turns out in a two or three
years it's actually relatively easy to
stick all these things together and you
thought you were doing five amazing
narrow systems well I just created
something that it figured itself out how
to combine all these things and now we
have what we were trying not to have so
um I think it's worth trying and also
being wary and aware of the concerns
that might happen if we combine them all
what do you think the relationship is
between generality and autonomy it seems
easier in my view to avoid uh creating
autonomous systems or more autonomous
systems if the systems are narrow is
there some sort of relationship in which
when you push on generality you also
push on autonomy I do think they're very
much linked as you said I kind of have a
similar view I think that if you were
having something that was designed for a
specific task it can be less General and
maybe less autonomous but as we talked
about before these things are nuanced
and there's overlapping aspects of we'll
say the distributions and some things
that aren't so with say credit card bank
fraud detection that sort of thing these
are pretty narrow they're highly
autonomous and that's they're not really
that General though right and you could
imagine something else that is pretty
General at the moment maybe most of the
language models they're pretty General
they're not really autonomous you ask it
to do something and if you didn't it
wouldn't do something on its own for the
most part uh so those those seem
entirely disconnected so like everything
in this world there's kind of um
multiple overlapping distributions where
you could imagine things are correlated
in some ways but in other examples they
may be pretty distinct I think there
will be pretty a high demand for
autonomous systems you mentioned the the
AI personal assistant I think what
consumers want from such a system is to
Simply tell it once to order the flight
tickets to wherever never think about it
again and just everything works out that
that sounds that sounds pretty great to
me at least what do you think about the
commercial incentives for autonomy I
think they're staggeringly high that's
the best way to say I I fully agree that
why wouldn't someone just want to can't
you do it for me like that let's be
honest we as humans want things to
happen and a lot of things that we do
want to happen require like
administrative burden I hate filling out
forms even if it takes 10 minutes
psychologically it seems to take an hour
there's a complete disconnect here so
like if someone could do that for me
something could do that for me yeah yeah
give it more power so I think this
really highlights uh we're getting at
the notion of control that I think if
we're we exploring how AI works how it's
going to function in our world we will
initially willingly give up control for
integrated AI systems yes you can
imagine the financial incentives are
huge to provide these products to people
the AI assistants they could be just
normal say personal assistants they
could be therapists they could be
companions all rolled into one the
military uh incentives the governments
have a desire to use them to help
citizens maybe even for surveillance of
citizens pros and cons all over the
place so there's all these reasons why
driving towards more AI good helping
consumers helping businesses helping
governments do things that they want to
achieve and as Things become more and
more integrated then it becomes
difficult to disentangle them or perhaps
stop it before it gets long too far say
more about that why is it difficult to
disentangle after you've integrated say
say people have begun using AI personal
assistance that's not a highrisk let's
say uh application but why is it
difficult to then stop using these
systems once you've begun using so
people kind of adapt to their world and
their expectations change a bit and we
can use a an already existing case study
so with the replica app which allows
people to have ai Companions and often
form relationships including romantic or
otherwise uh they went through a sort of
an upgrade or reboot or their tweaked
their model and their code such That
explicit conversations and things were
not allowed anymore and some of the
users who built up relationships with
these artificial AI little systems felt
devastated they felt like the person
that they knew and even loved is just
gone and they were depressed and so here
once you start along a path it sometimes
becomes very hard to shift out and we
know this perhaps for people who thought
well that replica thing I would never do
that most of us have a phone a
smartphone of some type and nowadays
it's pretty hard to not exist in this
world without one the utility is just so
high right it's great you have all these
functionalities and you can talk to
people and I don't have to sell the
phone on you but phones are great so
great in fact that it's really hard to
not have one so you know you could say
well I could choose not to have a phone
you could but at the moment you'd
actually be reducing your control by not
having a phone but if you really start
to think through the phone like okay
well the phone company could kind of
just brick my phone and stop it uh at
one point you know Apple put that
YouTube album on many people's phones
through the Play Store people didn't
quite like that they realized they
didn't have as much control as they
thought uh you kind of need the Internet
or something like it for most of the
applications on your phone when you're
using internet you're clicking I agree
to user agreements for apps or agreement
of cookies and tracking data all over
over the place so there's all these ways
in which we're again willingly giving up
power and control for again other types
of power and control we want to talk to
our friends we want to watch funny
videos we want to listen to podcasts or
watch them and that seems great but now
once we're here if you said to people
okay we're just shutting it all down you
can't like listen to podcasts anymore
you can't watch YouTube or like like it
sort of like more I don't know
dramatically is Facebook too big to fail
is it the case where although a lot of
people don't like Facebook for various
reasons a lot of people really do and
it's billions of users
is it the case that Facebook could just
go down and people wouldn't be upset a
lot of people have built their lives on
it that's where their friends are that's
where their photos are that's where
their memories are I actually enjoy the
memory feature what did I do on this day
five six seven years ago and I
appreciate that because again human
brains are fragile I sometimes did fun
things it's nice to remember them I
wouldn't have remembered it without the
prompt from the algorithm so in that
sense you sort of see that the
incentives very high it's going to be
hard to opt out I'm not saying people
should use social media all the time or
that social media doesn't have also lots
of problems but if you think of like
citizens in the world and what they
would want and how they would react you
could imagine it wouldn't go so well if
a government's just like okay we're just
not going to let people do this anymore
or when people say don't have internet
access for a very short period of time
that's usually very concerning for a lot
of people if you just didn't have it for
weeks and you weren't prepared this
would be truly destabilizing most people
nowadays of certain generation they
don't know where their friends live they
don't know their friends phone number
they may not know their email off by
heart Maybe and they don't know their
last name so so you have all these
things where like oh yeah that person
their handle on Twitter or their handle
on Instagram or who I interact with and
that's how you talk to them but if that
went away you would lose a vast social
network and almost have no ability to
reclaim it in any way if the
infrastructure was taken out of place so
all it to say is these pushpull tensions
where um once things are in place it
becomes very hard to disentangle and
that makes them even more and more
robust and desirable yeah we can think
about say all the the world's scientists
came to us and and told us the internet
is going to become very dangerous in 10
years we must shut the internet down
would would the world be able to
coordinate around this project would it
be possible for us to shut down the
internet given the uncertainties given
the different incentives that different
groups have I think that would be
extremely dangerous now the internet is
not going to it's not doesn't represent
a danger to us like like AI might do but
it's just uh thinking about when these
systems have begun become integrated
into our society how difficult it is to
step out of these systems again sure and
that's actually why I chose that example
in the book and when you're trying to
think about a artificial super
intelligence and why it's so powerful if
you talk to an average person one of the
first things they say is like can't you
just shut it off why don't you just shut
it down what's what's the big deal here
and I think the internet is probably the
most useful analogy as a comparator as a
again imagination device like okay well
let's think through the internet right
now the internet is very robust it is
designed to to be robust right because
not only do the average person want it
Global Commerce hinges upon it various
Municipal Services hospitals everything
else like so many things are now
integrated into the internet as anyone
who's had don't know like a a smart home
now is like what I can't get into my
house because the internet's down or I
can't control the temperature so again
pros and cons once you're integrated
right um all that to say is you know
there's cables that are crossing the
ocean and many other places that enable
the internet to happen and there is
currently no way to just shut down the
internet if like all the main
governments agreed then maybe you could
make a lot of progress in it but as I
say in the book um there'd be a huge
vulnerability like if you created an
internet Killswitch oh that's a great
opportunity for some terrorists to be
like why don't I just press the button
because it would wreak havoc and cause a
lot of damage so there's a huge
incentive to not even have a kill switch
available which is problem kind of one
or problem and solution number one and
then the second part is are we going to
get agreement from countries or
representatives to then actually
activate such a kill switch in an
emergency like you could imagine okay
people let's imagine let's sort of Ideal
World they've done their due diligence
we've somehow created a kill switch it's
very well protected it's not actually a
threat and we even have a protocol that
is designed with written clear uh
reasons when you would activate the kill
switch or not and then it comes time to
something bad happening and everyone
looks at the agreement that everyone
agreed upon uh the details and like well
I don't quite think point three has been
satisfied and someone else like of
course it has and we have minutes to
decide whether this is a good idea or
not I could just see that also being a
problem so this is the normal like human
complicated making decisions together
understanding the world differently and
it's not that there's no hope at all but
it just highlights that we'd have to do
a lot of work in advance and ensure that
such a thing could exist if we needed it
all I that to say is to your original
premise if the scientists presented
clear enough evidence I would hope that
we won't say everyone because everyone
doesn't agree on anything right but
there's enough people with enough
resources and power that the risk would
be clear enough that we should act and
put things in place place to make such a
thing happen with an artificial
superintelligence one could also see a
similar like well how would you shut it
off is it distributed in a way that even
is worse than the internet like you know
you could be on computer servers and
various places that are or are not
connected to the internet or fragments
of a ASI that could recombine into
something else so there's certainly a
lot of reasons to be concerned and um we
can use the present case of the internet
to see why it's going to be a challenge
how reliable do you believe current AI
systems are and and how reliable do you
think they'll be in the future I think
they are mixed and they will be mixed
and so to elaborate on that I think a
lot of these systems again they're
amazing certainly image generators you
know they're reliable or not right you
you kind of put something in you get
what you get uh do you get exactly what
you want very rarely I find with at
least image generators if someone's
looking over your shoulder they're like
that's amazing you're like that's not
quite what I wanted so there's a there's
a disconnect there but to the language
models I think they're generally great
and then you have to fact check
everything though there's already you
know numerous examples of uh lawyers
citing false precedents that didn't
exist um another case where I'm not sure
which system but one of them was asked
for examples of uh sexual harassment
cases involving lawyers and with
references and it spit back this
wonderful example of an individual who
was a professor who sexually harassed
some student on a trip to Alaska with
citations from you know Washington Post
or something like that the whole thing
was fake like the guy is is a law
professor but he's never been there he
want on to trip to Alaska there's no
incidence ever of sexual harassment so
the problem is these systems are very
very confident and convincing that the
analogy of a very good improv comedy
partner whatever game you want to play
it'll play along with you and in that
sense it can seem like it's doing more
than it is when it's kind of adapting to
who you are with reliability I think
there's an interesting Nuance here that
depending on the situation the AI is in
it may have to be like super extremely
reliable like you know
999999999 is still not enough because if
it's operating fast enough and it's
making a billion decisions a second then
even one in a billion you're like okay
is that one problem every second that
that could be catastrophic even if one
in a thousand were the actual problem
you'd very quickly reach that threshold
in other cases you could imagine well if
something's really super insightful like
it's coming up with interesting
scientific advancements or ways of
understanding the world well even if it
was 10% reliable like one in 10 even one
in 100 it might be still very very
valuable so I think it's going to be
very mixed in terms of reliability but
the main thing one would want is to have
an understanding of how reliable it is
before it is deployed and used in any
way because you don't want something
that you think is 99% reliable being 10%
reliable and the reverse of course
because that is confusing things again
we're going to kind of see how it it
plans out right with the self-driving
cars I think we just saw Crews say like
oh well you know we consult AI or some
network of people in some ways four or
5% of the time which sounds like a lot
but in another way is not if you look at
again the vast history of human
invention but it's not doing what it's
supposed to be doing how is reliability
different from alignment how are these
Concepts different is it just about
getting the AIS to do what we want in
both cases or how would you disentangle
here that's a that's a good question uh
so I think alignment kind of breaks down
into various different like related
issues and problems right does the AI do
what we want like who is we what are our
values uh that sort of things that's
that is the alignment Quagmire but
you're you're definitely right there is
sort of certainly some overlap where if
I've asked an AI for x and it's
delivering what seems to be X that seems
like it's reliable and therefore it
seems aligned with what I want so in
that sense I would say yeah there's a
lot of overlap between these terms that
said when we're thinking about alignment
It's usually the broader is this thing
going to cause a problem in some way or
another but well yeah actually now is
very similar so I'm appreciating that
these are these are highly linked
because if you think of alignment could
go an AI system could be misaligned for
several reasons right it could be due to
an accident it could be due to misuse by
malevolent actors or it could be you
know the AI itself becomes more capable
more power seeking and if it was
reliable in any of those ways it would
kind of make it worse but with the
accident example it does really seem
like well if an AI is misfunctioning it
makes it not reliable so on the Fly I
don't know if I'll commit to this but
I'll think like maybe reliability
becomes a bit of a subset of the
alignment accident issue and then of
course it would also relate to misuse in
a way these things are all very much
connected and that's something that's in
the book as well it's you can't make one
long chapter that's 3,000 pages so you
kind of have to like how can I put this
into different chunks even though these
things over overlap and interrelate yeah
so you mentioned these three categories
of of risks from AI um an accident
intentional misuse and Rogue AI which of
these categories worry you the most and
on which timelines so what are you most
worried about right now what about in 10
years and 20 years and 30 years yeah
30 years you're like oh 2053 let's think
about that for a moment I can't even
think that far in advance right now but
yes I think it's it's a great question
because you know you hear all these
things like what what's in the present
day right and I think at the moment it
is more of the accident and it is the
misuse just to clarify by accident we
kind of mean that the system's not quite
doing what we wanted to do right so when
Bing chat was aggressively misaligned
and it was kind of treating its users
badly earlier in 2023 then that
indicates that not what the machine was
supposed to do and this is the broader
category of you know people respond to
incentives and there are perverse
incentives right that you think you've
designed a law or a rule in one way and
then it turns out it's something else so
in that sense these things are happening
semi-frequently to some extent and
they're trying to like train them out
right and whether you know even saying
the wrong thing in terms of violence or
sexual imagery counts as accident as
well uh that's more nuance and we don't
really have to get into that but all
that to say is accident is a frequent
occurring problem right now uh with the
miss use that is also already happened
right people are using voice cloning
software to scam people out of money
they call a person usually a parent or a
grandparent pretend to be the person's
child because they voice cloned that
child's voice and say like I need money
please send it immediately and people
have already lost money now that seems
like a a bad case but of course it's not
nearly as dangerous as like new
bioweapons but that seems like it's also
plausible so if you sort of Imagine yes
why don't we say the next two three 5 10
years it seems like accident is already
happening misuse is most likely to
increase before more power seeking
autonomous behavior from AI itself or
the Rogue AI comes on board the concern
is since people who are building these
things don't know when you put in a
certain amount of compute or
computational capacity you get a certain
level of capability will there be a
dramatic jump in capability maybe maybe
not and that uncertainty is a problem so
while we it's it seems reasonable to say
well right now misuse is more the
near-term problem in the world of AI is
near-term six months
because then it's like oh yeah I meant
like until the end of 2024 and then it's
really also going to be about misuse and
power seeking so I think when you're
sort of talking average people or even
policy makers there's usually like a
multi-year sometimes multi- decade
concern in the back of their head or
sorry timeline in the back of their head
of how the world works and if you say
something's near-term versus long-term
you should clarify like Oh by misuse I
mean like one to two to three years and
then overlapping within one to five
years perhaps power seeking as well and
that's kind of how I would break it down
you're right about strategic foresight
which is making plans for different
scenarios how does that help us manage
these risks sure it's really just again
trying to think about ways to figure
things out without committing to a
specific outcome like a forecast would
right like you know again the weather
forecast I think is the best example of
the average person encountering
probabilistic assessments of the future
80% chance of rain tomorrow right uh
with forecast metaculus different
prediction markets what is the
likelihood of you know X event happening
at a certain time that's great I think
we need those and they are important I
think in addition we can use things like
foresight which explores a range of
plausible Futures so you can look at the
data you can look at analysis and you
can think what is the most likely
outcome what is most probable and that's
very useful but we can also think well
what's plausible let's play through and
kind of broad scenario planning is what
this is what might happen if if AI
becomes more prevalent if image
generators become more popular what
happens for example image generators
become more popular popular then more
people use them does that affect artists
let's just assume it affects artists and
artists lose work then what happens and
you kind of do this cascading first
order second order thing that really I
think helps open up the possibility
space the realm of what could happen now
sometimes it's hard to draw a direct
line of what do we do now but at least
you've opened up your mind of what could
be and once you start to think back all
the things that happened 5 10 15 20
years ago if you put yourself back 15
years ago and try to imagine what
happens then you realize oh people
didn't see a lot of things coming they
weren't open-minded enough or they
didn't see enough of the data there's a
bit of hindsight bias right or as
tempting to think of course that thing
was foreseeable and many things are not
but with foresight I really think it's
very useful just to again open up our
minds so with the AI issue you can take
a example where say artificial super
intelligence arrives in 10 years just
assume that's happened then work
backwards So what had to happen for that
future to come into existence what if it
was 20 years what if it was 50 years and
you can kind of think like okay maybe if
it's 10 years current projections seem
to hold but maybe if it was 20 years
there was some hiccups there was some
complications we didn't understand the
complexity of certain things and we hit
certain walls 50 years I think a lot of
us would be like well I don't know we
just got something wrong we didn't
understand the nature of what we were
dealing with and a lot of projections
now would be wrong and you can do that
in a variety of ways so I think it it
opens up the ability to think about
these issues in different ways without
committing to something but
fundamentally it also really helps
challenge assumptions if you sort of
have discussions with people of what
they expect the future to be like and
you could break that down do you expect
it like what's your preference for the
future what would you not want the
future to be like what do you think is
most likely and so by doing all these
different sort of different nuances
different themes about what they think
the future might be like you might be
able to have someone realize like oh
wait my expectation of the future is
very much aligned with my preference for
the future right because that's how a
lot of people are but maybe my
preferences are not that relevant to how
the future actually exists and then they
can go oh I didn't realize that was
happening or even just you know with AI
stuff some people don't realize how
advanced these machines already are and
if you can say like this thing has
already happened then what happens it
really does help people think oh maybe
this could be a concern yeah I think
it's great to make plans for different
AI scenarios but I do worry that these
plans will work best if we have gradual
improvements so say 10% Improvement per
year we can go back to our plans we can
get feedback from the world adjust our
plans but what if AI progress is more
bumpy and much faster than 10% per year
does this does this make strategic
foresight less useful well perhaps less
useful but not not useful right it still
has utility it's sort of like we have to
again make decisions under uncertainty
and so we should do the best we can we
should put resources into figuring out
and we should map different
possibilities and try to communicate
those broadly to others to get feedback
and see what things could be yes you're
right if things are dramatic if there's
a big step change in capabilities uh it
doesn't mean all that work wasn't useful
at all but it might mean like oh I have
to flip page five all those things I
thought were going to happen in my
document have now already been passed
what now but hopefully having like these
conversations themselves allow us to
plan even better like okay again the use
to SC are planning it's most useful when
there's like 10% increases what happens
if it's 50 what happens if it's a 200
and again you might not be able to
really figure it out and have a perfect
plan but having something is better than
nothing and sometimes again just
thinking it through you at least get
through all say is like the emotional uh
complications either the barrier
intellectually or even viscerally that
oh my God this thing just happened and
sometimes people need a bit of time to
sit with that like okay now imagine
something is much more capable than
anything ever and it's highly General
let's think through what that might be
like and you can even think through how
you might feel to then better make a
decision when it's happening because
again if you're trying to make decisions
and things are happening very quickly
urgency rarely helps decision-making so
you discussed this fact I would say that
that we are living in an unusual times
in terms of economic growth in terms of
scientific papers published per year in
terms of the exponential growth of
computing power available for for a
certain dollar amount yeah that that's
that's one aspect of the world we're
living in another aspect might be that
ideas are getting harder to find we have
many more researchers for the same
amount of scientific breakthrough
economic growth might be slowing down in
in certain countries say say we have
these two trends Trends and and you can
tell me whether you think these these
Trends are are actually occurring which
of these Trends are going to win out are
we going to hit diminishing returns or
are we are we on a path to even um
stronger exponential growth going
infinite
right like I can find ideas on the
internet very easily what do you mean
they're hard to find um jokes aside so I
I appreciate you highlighting that this
is certainly not a new idea but I really
wanted to again average person hasn't
thought much about these issues like
where are we sitting right now and to
think how humans currently live again
not everyone there are billions of
people without food water electricity
that sort of thing or at least hundreds
of millions things are very different
than they used to be so I wanted to give
a sense of the grand sweep of how things
are very different to show just how much
change has occurred to then say well if
so much change has occurred it's at
least reasonable possible plausible to
think a lot of change might also occur
in the future so if you go back you know
millions of years you know protohumans
are still developing at one point you
know was it 1.6 million years ago we
have a hand axe which is a sharp Stone
tool and that was the best thing for a
million years a million years 50,000
generations of people and you're like
what know I was like well I made this
sharp Stone slightly sharper like okay
well that's not that great in
advancement compared to like the iPhone
and all the different new releases there
uh that said for people who are
sticklers I'm sure there were also
various wooden tools they OB don't
preserve as well Humanity also lost
knowledge about how to make certain
tools at various points throughout
history which is something that's
difficult to imagine now that we would
lose knowledge about how to print books
or something like that um maybe at the
at the very Cutting Edge of the
technology stack we can imagine that we
might lose knowledge it seems difficult
for us to imagine now I think losing
knowledge of how to create basic
products I think you're right uh as the
nature of the world has become more
industrialized certainly making at
particular product often requires many
many people sometimes thousands
sometimes millions in the entire supply
chain So that's its own types of
complexity where now well maybe someone
could have made a pencil and someone
still can nowadays it's a whole team and
Company and industries and machines is
it the case that we're going to keep
growing sort of getting more advanced
and things going to keep changing I
think it depends on what we measure and
I'm well aware that the economist will
say innovation has slowed or
productivity is down in certain ways and
I think that's important I don't I don't
want to say it isn't but from like the
the user normal human user experience it
seems like things are still uh
remarkable right now you could say most
of it's in the information technology
space it's the Internet it's the
computers it's the phones we like
where's our new plane or a washer dryer
or the car or that sort of thing and I
guess I think that the changes in the
internet in that space like that we're
easily doing this podcast are
significant in a similar way to some of
these other things now yes the invention
of like a dishwasher is a truly big
difference in terms of how it affected
life but so are recent inventions so I
don't want to say things are going to
continue forever that seems unlikely
because it just also makes no sense
conceptually usually there's an curve in
terms of how these things develop right
and it's hard to know where we are in
the curve I would just say more
comfortably for the next little while it
does seem computer computer technology
that whole domain is going to increase a
lot and then that's going to Ripple
through now whether some people think
this isn't enough um I don't know I'm
I'm I guess I'm less concerned about
that I mean I am concerned about like
economic growth being good for human
development in that sense but that we're
running out of ideas I don't know
there's still lots of great ideas right
and in fact I think with the AI thing
like maybe we need to slow down some of
this development because we haven't
figured out how to deal with the ideas
we already have I also think it's
interesting as you said scientists now
sometimes on papers there's 10 50 a
hundred or some like hundreds of
scientists to do some of these things
usually it's partical particle physics
or something in AI or machine learning
or maybe even biology and yes it's not
like when it was with I know you picture
your Darwin your Aristotle or
something's like oh yes I think the
nature of the world is blah and I've
unlocked some mystery of the universe
and yes you could think that there are
some diminishing returns but at the same
time there's lots we haven't figured out
right uh how gravity interacts at the
quantum level even if what the right
interpretation of quantum mechanics is
Will these things be figured out could
we build Fantastical uh ways of
capturing energy more than solar even
right and these sorts of things so I
guess when I think of the new solar and
wind stuff which didn't exist when I was
younger uh the fact that you know
there's immersive VR things exist didn't
exist when I was younger planes haven't
changed a lot sure but now people have
gone to space uh casually like again in
the history of the world none of this
has ever happened so yes on a
multi-decade span it may seem like
things have slowed but if you really
take a step back thousands of years even
on a million year scale it's all
squished right in the past couple
hundred years and so like let's just
let's keep these things in mind but
let's see how the next couple decades
pan out let's talk about alignment so
one objection you might give to the
whole project of alignment is to say
that humans can't agree on what values
we should have philosophers haven't been
able to figure out ethics what is it
that we're trying to align AI with if we
haven't determined our values yet it's
it's a great question and it is
currently unsolved and in some ways
we're going to have to muddle through
that would be my concise answer it's
sort of like what do we do when humans
disagree well we try to come together in
some sort of compromise some sort of
consensus hopefully some sort of
democratic system where people don't
necessar get everything they want but
they get enough that the world functions
decently for most people it's not
perfect by any means but then compared
to what right the Winston chural Line so
with AI yes this is the technical
alignment issue which I think is
critically important this is more like
does the AI do something we didn't want
to do like by an accident by a technical
point of view but yes if we solve the
technical alignment problem that's great
that's amazing that's that's difficult
but it's still going to be amazing and
then there's this other problem which
was always there that slots right into
place well now what who decides the fate
of the world type thing right and if
these systems are as powerful as they
are it does seem very bizarre how we're
currently going about it right yes we do
have states that are starting to issue
executive orders like the White House
did or other regulation or the EU AI act
but right now it seems I'll to say weird
that a few people are sort of not
controlling the fate of the world but by
their own standards by their own
statements they're developing by design
by their own goal at very very powerful
systems that could have vast control and
abilities so what what is going on here
right this is where the book is kind of
just trying to raise awareness of the
yes even if this thing about AI is
solved in a technical sense there's this
other problem about how do we ensure
like everyone has a voice how do we Ure
people are represented is there going to
be even greater ow power imbalances and
inequalities that will result in a way
that's truly disruptive so I think again
it's like a call to Arms we need a lot
more people thinking about it we need a
lot more people aware of it and even
like a if then scenario like okay so say
a has developed what's the plan how will
resources be distributed will these
companies just grow to you know
multi-trillion dollar quadrillion dollar
things who knows how far it goes does
something end up getting nationalized
these are delicate things maybe to say
in certain environments but hopefully
conversations are at least happening
behind the scenes of okay let's plan
through again the scenarios if something
isn't aligned uh with other people uh
and they could use it for malicious use
that's one thing but just the normal my
preferences are different than yours and
that may make your life a lot worse
that's something we really need to pay
attention to yeah I think also the some
hope that given our kind of humans have
a shared evolutionary history we have we
we share a lot of of of our values uh
even though we we also disagree strongly
with each other all the time I think
there's some hope that we won't have to
actually get as something like a final
theory of of Ethics or something and I
and I I want to say we we should
definitely not uh stop working on
alignment until we have such a theory
that we can then pluck into to our uh to
our AI systems I I think we can probably
agree on some basics of life and and
then yeah as you say model through so
thinking about health care for example I
I think most people can agree that most
people should have access to or all
people should have access to Fantastic
Healthcare and that's that's that's
something where AI might be able to help
and and and then we can go on to the
next thing and the next thing in the
next thing I think there's some sort of
a there might be a too much focus on
trying to trying to develop a perfect
theory of of ethics and we should we
should as you say model through well I
think that sort of might be the only way
right as you said philosophers academics
anyway all humans sort of been working
on this for thousands of years and of
course we don't all agree and and
importantly we don't often agree with
ourselves right we change over time your
preferences from a child to as an adult
to maybe even five years ago like I feel
differently well were you correct five
years ago or now uh oh which you know
which system which value system did you
get the AI was it supposed to to lock in
was it supposed to supposed to know
better uh I think it's a very it's a
very interesting but also very
concerning space that like you though I
think like can't we agree on some Basics
and we could sort of think the United
Nations Declaration of Human Rights or
development like most countries did sign
on to these things and there is a
general sense like okay people should
have food like we'll get to Healthcare
in a moment but like food Water
Sanitation know grade up to grade eight
primary education like these seem to be
universals and so hopefully yes with
abundance from the AI we can all agree
like can't we just like and tuberculosis
can't we really solve this malaria thing
can't we have everyone more educated but
there will always be someone who
disagrees there'll always be someone
from a different angle there are
malevolent actors there are currently 40
million people in modern day slavery
clearly they are there because other
people are doing terrible things in
various ways or the situations they find
themselves in are so compromised that
said like how do you ever like get rid
of that and as you said we we kind of
muddle through as well at the same time
certain things remain wholly
unacceptable with the AI it is the
concern that and this is of course race
Dynamics all over the place that if
certain malevolent actors get their way
first then they may then be able to
disempower or displace what we'll say is
the loose reasonable majority that
thinks everyone should have food water
Healthcare and education in sort of
traditional discussions of alignment we
imagine perhaps that we would sit down
and hand code human values into AI
systems and then we we we we thought
about how complex human values are and
and that was a cause of Despair how
could we ever summarize something as
complex and inconsistent as as human
values do you think that large language
models change this picture because large
language models can digest all of human
knowledge and then at least they can
pretend to have a knowledge of human
values ethics uh psychology and so on is
it the case that large language models
make the alignment problem easier hm
that is has a great question I think
that's one of the things we're currently
figuring out right from what I
understand open AI plans to use AI
models to help solve the AI alignment
problem and in a way we need you know AI
to assess and evaluate and to test to
see if it is aligned so that in ai ai is
inherently involved but to your your
general question is maybe and what I
think is a perhaps interesting
development of this so what if the AI
system looks at all human knowledge
right and it says you know what I
figured it out guys everyone this is
what you should do we're like I don't I
don't want to do that
it's like but but by your own standards
you said you cared about these things
and then human's like no no but I didn't
not not really you know come on and so
what in in the book before I talk about
the more like AI alignment problem as
people know it I talk about Isaac aov's
laws Robotics and I think this was just
the very easy way into like simple rules
to align computer systems don't work
when you say don't harm something you're
like that seems reasonable that seems
obvious of course put it in the machine
you're like what does that mean exactly
like don't harm at all like if someone
needs to get surgery where they have to
be cut into uh does that count what if
it's a risky surgery um when you say
don't harm anyone does that include
non-action this is whole the Omission
bias right where if you drown someone we
see that as a terrible thing if you let
someone drown well we see that as a bad
thing but not usually as bad as the
intentional drowning so is an AI system
now supposed to think well wait I'm
letting people suffer people are
currently dying in poverty needlessly
should I be doing something about that
well by your own standards you said
don't allow humans to cause harm or come
to harm what am I supposed to do now and
you can see that pry much disconnected
maybe the thing short circuits yeah does
does harm imply any probability of harm
then you're kind of you you cannot move
you cannot do anything because anything
any action at all could cause harm it it
it just doesn't work no exactly and so I
think it'll be very useful for AI
systems to provide Insight but like any
sort of human Enterprise thing we might
get back an answer we don't want or
that's very hard for us and whether
people will take that on board is also
going to be highly variable like for for
people who are very much interested in
ethical reflection and philosophy they
might have made like substantial
progress and they realize you know my
beliefs mean I shouldn't do X and
therefore I don't do X and a lot of us
are like I know I shouldn't do X but
sometimes I still do because I'm a human
and you know again progress is good it's
not to say that people should be
absolutist about these things it just
sort of highlights the difficulties of
the human system the human nature of the
whole thing do you think current AI
systems have
self-preservation good question I would
think I would probably defer to like
who's doing the most cuttingedge
research now in the the in in the
advanced Labs from what I understand is
slightly but not a lot there are some uh
examples I think more in like the
theoretical or there's like a prototype
where they've played around with certain
systems and you know simulated
environments and the system does seem to
engage in certain Behavior to protect
itself to achieve a goal whether it's
full-on self-preservation as we commonly
understand it I don't think we're there
yet but yeah I would I would kind of
think like well there's probably some
paper on archive that I haven't had a
chance to read yet that may say
otherwise but you think that AI systems
will develop self-preservation as we get
more advanced AI I do or at least I
think I do to the extent that we should
be concerned about it again nothing's
100% here but there's enough of a risk
that you know the whole steuart Russell
you can't fetch coffee if you're dead
thing to have a system do anything it
has to exist and to me it is reasonable
it is plausible that to achieve anything
to exist and once you know that you
might engage in various activities to
ensure that you do exist now maybe there
are ways to contain this or to
circumvent it where you know you somehow
clearly specify a goal with a certain
amount of error bars and then the system
is supposed to shut itself down after
it's done that goal perhaps but when we
talked about before the incentives for
autonomous systems that are highly
capable highly fast and so on will then
sort of have a disconnect with something
that shuts itself down all the time you
imagine like oh I like to use my phone
and after I send one text I shut the
phone off and then I shut it I turn it
back on like well that seems really
painful and slow right and people just
might not do it so I think it is
plausible that the systems will engage
in such Behavior H in a way like the
expectation would be they probably would
I guess I'm trying to say the default
expectation to me is that something
that's very very intelligent will
probably engage in these behaviors so we
should be on the lookout for it and
really try to figure out if they are or
they're not versus the expectation that
they wouldn't it doesn't seem to me that
gbt 4 when I talk to it is trying to
self-preservative but it seems to me
that can just click stop on the chat
whenever I want or close the tab
whenever I want and there's there's
nothing the system can do do you think
do you think self-preservation will
emerge together with more autonomous
systems that's that's a great point so
yes right now if you think about like
how could this thing be autonomous I
literally you know close it I click the
button and it goes away it's not like
secretly hiding somewhere to our to our
knowledge I guess there's a small
probability that it is already and well
that's the thing that's so I by the way
I tried to be careful in the book where
like AI That's super smart can do
anything right because then you kind of
get into these almost non-falsifiable
things like well maybe it's secretly
doing the thing and it's so good at
Deception that it looks like it isn't
dece now I think there's something to it
and we should be wary about it but I
also think we have to be careful because
those explanations are not satisfying to
most people oh look it can do anything
well tell me about it oh anything you're
like well I don't understand what you
mean uh to your point though yes right
now I'm not concerned about that I don't
see an issue with that that said as we
start to get beyond the gp4 or Gemini
and these Frontier models I think it's a
very important thing to ESS not only
before deployment but in the training
stage there should be methods and
benchmarks in place and even asking the
labs what are your expectations for the
capabilities of your models throughout
the process and if they're the lab
themselves are like consistently wrong
in a certain direction like oh we
thought it' be certainly a capable and
it ends up being more capable every time
you're like that's not a good track
record so next time when you say it's
not going to be as capable as we thought
it probably will be uh just some sort of
way to get at um how we might understand
these things as it goes in the future
again we currently have autonomous
systems right as I said so they're doing
banking stuff they're doing fraud
detection they're doing cyber secur
things they're stopping missiles that
are being bonded the incentives to have
these things become more autonomous uh
will be there and then again if the
system doesn't exist it can't really do
its job I want to be careful here that
there's a sort of the as if goals right
that the system only needs to act as if
it is engaging in self-preservation it
doesn't have to have like a I'm an AI I
have a certain goal I need to exist it
may do something like that but it
doesn't have to and I don't want us to
sort of think it needs to be the case
it's more just going to engage in
various we'll say from our perspective
reasonable goal oriented processes to
make it more likely to achieve its goal
and some of those will involve getting
more power to ensure its own existence
so we can serve that end now again maybe
not but there's enough of a maybe so
that we should be very careful there's a
bunch of emergent capabilities in AI
systems that could be problematic if
we're trying to align these systems so
so we're talking about power seeking
deception man manipulation of humans
using humans to achieve goals in the
physical world and so on which of these
traits do you worry about the most and
and where do you think we are on the
road to these traits how close do you
think we are to to having manipulative
or deceptive or power seeking system I
don't think we're there yet but what
could happen in a short period of time
could definitely be the case so on the
first uh example just the emergence
itself I think a lot of people think the
recent large language models your you
know chat GPT gp4 and cloud and whatnot
they are largely largely emergent in a
lot of their capabilities right you have
these systems that were trained on
mainly English and then they can speak
other languages that was not the plan
right or it was trained mostly on some
sort of Corpus of text and then it can
also do computer programming so it's not
that if someone had thought through a
lot of this they would have realized oh
maybe it will also do the thing it's
that from our perspective it did seem
like certain Behavior emerged in a way
that was unexpected or unplanned as at
least in some cases in some domains so
all have to say is emergence seems to be
like all over the place right especially
if you try to prompt a model in a
certain way and you get a certain thing
which you didn't think it might do but
then it would it was just strange to me
knowing something about the training
process of of dpt4 interacting with the
system in my native language and and
talking to it perfectly in Danish and
seeing that it's it's pretty capable in
my native language was kind of a a
surprise and an interesting experience
and I I I I believe that a lot of people
have have had that experience of of
talking to to it in their in their
native language and knowing that it
wasn't trained specifically to do that
uh it's quite impressive I I agree I
think it's stly impressive it's hard to
think of a human parallel because
clearly Danish was somewhere in the
training set right it's not like it read
English and then it like invented Danish
no no of course not just for everyone
else but at the same time it's like why
you have a test coming up it's an
English test here's a whack of material
and like study all of it but focus on
the English like Okay and like and then
Danish like well what and of course it's
not just Danish it's numerous other
languages it's also math not usually the
addition which it has trouble with but
like complicated math and if you know
famous mathematicians like Terren TOA
are using these systems like it really
helps improve my workflow you're like
okay well that's clearly a significant
indicator of capability uh so you could
also imagine if then someone's like we
really need a dedicated math system this
goes to that General versus uh narrow
would it be more capable it seems to
think like it should be more capable but
it's possible the general somehow is
more capable right then fine tuning
tweaks it um to to your other question
though I am concerned to sort of
thinking about sort of that security
nature of things right if you're looking
through the world from a security lens
security mindset you think like where
are the weak links right and all
companies and even individuals deal with
this to some extent and people can be
manipulated in a sort of social
engineering way right people get
information just by calling someone up
pretending to be someone else or there's
more over cyber hacking and whatnot but
with uh AI systems it's almost like you
take the normal problems that already
exist and there are also still problems
in the AI space so whether there's uh
you know people who are bribable people
who are manipulatable people you can
hire off the dark web like it's one of
these sort of um things that most people
don't like to think about for obvious
reasons but there are like Hitmen you
can hire them to kill people they just
don't hire them to kill you because
you're not that important right like
thankfully right it's this whole weird
world you're like what happens what type
of criminal activity like there's actual
criminals who do things and so to think
that AI systems won't liaz with if
they're trying to cause harm uh nef ious
individuals who literally can be paid to
do crime uh to make themselves more
capable it's it seems like that' be an
oversight so I I guess I'm concerned
about a range of these things again at
the moment not that concerned about that
much of it but because it often takes
months years to address problems you
need the infrastructure in place now you
need the what is the problem type
conversations problem definition is very
important people often speak past each
other so if we can agree that an AI
system that would have an ability to
manipulate people or that would have an
ability to hire people to do certain Tas
Tas is a potential problem that's a good
start and I think we already saw when
gp4 was being evaluated there was that
famous case where again the the AI
system itself did not do this but it was
liasing with the researchers in between
and the gp4 was able to hire someone off
task rabbit and lie about why it needed
that person to fill out a capture to
build a computer code now again the
system didn't do it but it's like well
it doesn't seem that complicated to
connect those things or to have enabled
the system to do it so if it was the
case months ago that if a system with a
bit of tweaks could have hired someone
off the internet to circumvent something
to stop AI systems and lie about why it
did it why wouldn't this be possible in
the future it's already happened right
it's like okay so now imagine something
that's more capable more capable of
lying can sort of think through step
byep on its own would know how to
navigate a sis once it has more examples
again this human uh human history
fiction novels movies or even just
current events uh are replete with
numerous examples of people deceiving
each other and engaging in various
complic at nefarious schemes and you
could imagine that as a wonderful
training data set for someone trying to
cause harm do you think we will get
something like a unified solution to the
alignment problem uh like something that
solves all of these um problems that we
just talked about deception manipulation
power seeking and so on another way to
ask maybe is do you think we'll we'll
we'll get something like the theory of
evolution which solves a bunch of
distinct problems in a in a general and
and simple way or will it look more like
wacka solving one problem moving on to
the next problem I like I like it's the
option between evolution and wack-a-mole
[Music]
I the evolution of wacka so I think um
it's probably a bit more the wacka and
the reason here is again like the
straightforward logic of human
incentives and human behaviors so say
someone's develops A system that as you
said reliably does what it's supposed to
do well that means it could be used for
good or bad right at the moment the AI
systems and I briefly mentioned this in
the book they're kind of sort of loosely
corporate American Western values like
what's acceptable and what's not but
what it does mean is that someone is
sort of has their hand on the lever
someone is sort of manipulating the
system to do X and not y so it is
already the case that certain values are
being implemented or at least displayed
through these systems of a certain type
now if you just had the alignment of you
know it does what we want if someone was
a you know malevolent actor and it
wanted to cause harm it could use the
thing to do what we want so then you're
like well is is the alignment problem
really going to solve not having bad
people do bad things or not having we'll
say even desperate or confused people
inadvertently do bad things that's the
other thing while I would say people
could be bribed and manipulated people
could also just be persuaded like their
child is very sick they're desperate
they need money or maybe like oh my
child has a certain form of cancer he is
like look I can I can cure it I just
read a thousand papers I just need some
resources I understand desperation could
also be a factor here so trying to get
rid of like not say everyone's evil in
Affairs out there it's just like there's
many reasons why why someone might give
up power and it's hard to imagine how
sort of the alignment problem might sort
of address all that in earlier version
of the book actually there were four
different alignment problems I was going
to talk about but I thought that was too
complicated for my audience it really
was like you're not fully aligned with
yourself we're not fully aligned with
each other uh we're not necessar fully
aligned with AI and then AI itself might
not be aligned with us or with itself if
there's multiple AIS but I thought okay
you know let's let's streamline this to
then think about as asm's laws robotics
to make easy that that type of alignment
is a problem and then the more
traditional the alignment problem stuff
right now there's a bunch of proposals
on the table for making AI safe there's
a lot of attention on this issue in
policy circles and I think you you had a
great discussion in the book about
principles for selecting among these
proposals for AI safety maybe you could
talk a bit about these principles sure
thing so yes there's a lot of great uh
proposals out there but it's sometimes
useful to take a step back and even
think like what's the framework that
we're even been using to think through
these proposals and even if one said out
loud like that's kind of obvious like
sure but let's put it down because
sometimes what you think is obvious is
obvious to you and not someone else or
you see where you might agree right if
you have five principles and I have five
maybe three overlap and that's great so
I kind of tried to keep it simple and
think through like what are the three
main ways we might want to think about
this or that should be a part of any
principle and so that's verification and
Agility adaptability that's the second
one and the third one is defense in
depth so verification is just realizing
that we need to verify you know it's
it's nice to say trust but verify but
the idea is that everyone should be
accountable there should be transparency
there should be verification mechanisms
built in and if actors in the AI space
the companies that are developing these
things say there's no problem there
should be no problem then let's let's
let's verify everything right if you
think you're not developing anything
harmful let's have that as a backbone
we'll say of any proposal that you want
to ensure that things are happening as
they're understood to be happening as
much as possible and even the idea that
people will try to circumvent
verification as they always do in this
world at least to some extent by some
actors that should also be built into
the process so you can't just take
people's words for it I can't remember
the quote but some's like they can't be
grading their own homework here in these
AI systems like these AI companies it
just doesn't work that way and again
even if they're not necess nefarious
great we'll just have it all above board
and have Ure that verification is there
the second one agility and adaptability
again this isn't like a novel Insight
but it's just really trying to highlight
how fast moving the spaces and how we
really have to think through what if it
happens even faster right that a lot of
times in the policy regulatory legal
space things take months years to work
through the system and what if it has to
be much less than that or what if you
have a law that you thought was useful
that you know usually what happens is
the law is developed it somehow it comes
to exist in the world sometimes it
interacts with challenges from the
courts there's some sort of settled
agreement the law seems to have some
sort of a standard or consistency and
then maybe it's challenged again in the
future that's a multi-year sometimes
multi- deade process for the AI stuff it
might have to be multiple months
multiple years so how can we even start
thinking about changing almost the
Machinery of government and parts of the
world to at least address these sorts of
things yes you can have amendments to
laws but really thinking through um that
this is a factor and that people should
be prepared for things happening faster
than usual uh the third one defense in
depth this comes more from cyber
security than the military definition
and that's that we need multiple layers
of Defense you don't expect any one
particular proposal or one particular
action to lead to safety or security but
you're trying to have multiple layers so
if any one of them fails and you
actually expect them to fail that there
are others there to sort of pick up the
slack makes a lot of sense all of these
principles so in the book you you
discuss eight proposals for for safe AI
Innovation maybe you could talk about
your favorites here what are the most
important things it's like how do you
choose a favorite child right uh no I
just think the amusing so why there's
eight by the way and why isn't there 10
and why isn't there seven well you know
eight seemed like a good number I think
this really encapsulated what I thought
were a good number also why I want these
proposals or why I want these to be
discussed is not that these are again
definitive the whole book is trying to
be very open-minded Solutions oriented
we need more people working on this and
we all need to come together to work on
this so if it is the case that someone's
like you know what most of your
proposals don't work for me I be like
okay which ones do right because there's
as we know this is unfortunate tension
that exists sometimes in different AI
safety and ethics communities or some
people who are more focused on we'll say
present concerns like algorithmic bias
are taking issue with people who are
more concerned about existential threats
and this is an unfortunate Division I
mean there's some rationale behind it
right because allocation of resources
but I think it's largely just an
unfortunate way the world world has
turned out and it doesn't have to be
this way so with the AG proposals there
could be like okay yes some of those are
maybe more X risk or existential risk
oriented but what are the ones that work
for you now some sort of liability
that's one of the proposals great some
sort of a transparency or identification
you're interacting with an AI system and
that's where I'm trying to like you know
allive branches all over the place build
Bridges here that if certain proposals
don't work pick the ones that do or show
me your list of eight let's see what
works and let's work on those together
that seems like is going to have the
most broadest support that is going to
be good for all these issues I think if
we took a step back some sort of
liability for these systems again why do
people do anything well they respond to
incentives and if they are held liable
sometimes personally liable for how
these systems malfunction that is
usually a good lever and it can't just
be a sort of distributed sense of like
well I did a thing but I'm not really
accountable like well let's think
through what makes the most sense here
and maybe if you are responsible for
Distributing an AI model even though you
didn't create it you do bear some of the
liability here some of the
accountability I think compute
governance is also a very important one
here this is sort of like getting a
sense of and controlling who has access
to which chips the US has already
implemented some of these things with
you know export controls on China and
some recent additions to that which are
making it even more restrictive the book
Chip War is a fantastic exploration of
some of these issues uh and so in that
sense if you think of the main reasons
why AI is increasing in capability
usually people think there's three main
inputs right you have the computational
power you have lots of data and then you
have like the algorithms itself which
are partly a human thing like just
talent pool that are building these
things but also insights from science
and other domains and even AI itself so
how can you as a as a taking a big step
back as a system as a government as an
international organization of sorts
think about how to control or at least
have a sense of influencing these inputs
and data is kind of everywhere it's
really hard to stop people accessing
data uh with the talent pool the
algorithms that also seems like we want
free mobility of labor for the most part
right we don't want to lock people up
and tell them they can't work certain
places or anything else that seems bad
but with the compute governance it is
more of a tangible physical thing
there's a chip which is understood at
least to some extent of what it does and
how it works and getting a sense of
where these chips go could be very very
useful now to to reassure some people
this isn't for all AI systems this is
really the frontier AI model so for the
average consumer the average AI business
the average product this doesn't really
affect them at all it's more that are
you using the most advanced chips and do
you have thousands and thousands of them
that you can put together in a cluster
to then train highly capable models so
it really is something that sort of like
those tax like oh if you make more than
hundred million dollars this is a tax
and people like I would never want to be
taxed like that like well don't worry
you never will so for the most part it
doesn't affect most people or most
businesses but I think that's very
useful now how you go about it with the
proposals I have an idea I have some
sketch I have some detail but I always
want to say like let's think this
through what is the best version of this
that could go forward with the most
recent evidence with the most recent
analysis what is the best version is it
useful to have you know ways that the
chips can't communicate with each other
as much so you can't bundle more like
weaker chips together or should there be
some sort of remote kill switch even for
the chips themselves we can't shut down
the internet uh maybe let's let's study
it let's see if that's viable if it
turns out it's not for good or bad
reasons then we wouldn't do that but
really trying to think through how can
we access some of that stuff one of your
proposals is about investing in AI
Safety Research so here I'm imagining
technical AI Safety Research at least
when I try to try to see this from the
perspective of a funer I worry that it's
extremely difficult to choose among
proposals what should you fund how
should you respond to an applicant being
optimistic about solving the problem is
pessimism a sign that you that you
understand the problem in a deeper way
or is optimate you know there's so many
complexities and in a sense this is just
normal science funding but I worry that
this is even stronger in in trying to to
fund AI safety do you have any ideas
about how to go about evaluating
proposals for technical AI Safety
Research I think you rais a great point
and and the smile was just the idea that
yes if someone is more depressed or less
optimistic about solving the problem do
they get more money right intellectual
integrity and you know epistemic modesty
and all these things and maybe that's
the case so I would say that I don't NE
have specifics I think it's sort of like
do we agree that there are currently a
lot more people that are trying to
increase capabilities that are concerned
about safety like do we agree this as a
fact whether the numberers like 100 to
one or more or less you know AI
capabilities researchers versus safety
researchers do we agree there's some
sort of large discrepancy and that
probably shouldn't be the case I think
Ian Hogarth had that nice like sort of
two- chart graph like well one Line's
going way up and the other one's not
really going up and meeting it at all so
if there is a disconnect between safety
and capabilities what should we do about
that and it seems like somehow funding
Safety Research seems like a good idea
sort like let's start there if we can't
get agreement there then that's an issue
but assuming there is some agreement yes
how to actually go about it and here I
would probably kind of defer to people
who have already been in the space for
several years and have them like kind of
talk to each other and see what are some
current best practices you're right it's
an absolute mess and how to study safety
without increasing capabilities seems to
be one of the biggest issues of all and
as anthropic and other people have
reasonably said even though it's kind of
a bitter pill to swallow but we need the
advanced AI system to study the safety
of the systems and it doesn't really
make sense to try to think about the
safety of say GPT 4 or GPT 5 if you're
currently working on gpt2 or gpt3 not
from what I understand not that much of
what you learned is going to be
applicable and translatable so I think
it's a really important issue um and I
think it's just sort of really orienting
people to realize look how much
capabilities are increasing and there is
not nearly the attention paid on safety
not at all and in fact some of the
organizations don't care at all and so
if people really onboarded that okay
some of these people seem to be more
responsible actors and some of them
don't terrible safety at all they're
just trying to make the product as fast
as possible dump it into the world like
I think it was the mistal AI uh then we
should be concerned great there's a lot
of complexities there we could talk for
hours on this topic Darren thanks for
talking with me it's been a pleasure my
pleasure as well Gus thanks so much